Muhammad Hijab boasts that he has
refuted the best Christian apologetic
argument against
Islam. I think the Islamic dilemma is
the best Christian apologetic argument
against Islam, too. So, thanks for the
cosign, Hijab. Unfortunately, hijab
doesn't come within a trillion miles of
refuting our argument. Instead, he only
pretends to refute our argument. Dawa is
deception. For many years, the deception
was geared mainly towards duping people
into converting to Islam. But ever since
the avalanche of apostasy sent shock
waves through the Umah, the deception
has been primarily aimed at keeping
Muslims from abandoning their religion.
How do you keep a Muslim from abandoning
his religion in the age of the
internet? You lie to him. And no one is
better at lying to our Muslim friends
than Muhammad Hijab, who finally posted
a response to what we call the Islamic
dilemma. The Islamic dilemma is a simple
argument that goes something like this.
The Quran affirms the inspiration,
preservation, and authority of the
Jewish and Christian scriptures. But the
Quran contradicts the Jewish and
Christian scriptures on basic doctrines,
which leads to a dilemma because there
are only two possibilities.
Either Jews and Christians have the
inspired, preserved, authoritative word
of God or we don't. It's one or the
other. If we have the inspired,
preserved, authoritative word of God,
Islam is false because Islam contradicts
our scriptures. Alternatively, if we
don't have the inspired, preserved,
authoritative word of God, Islam is
false because the Quran affirms the
inspiration, preservation, and authority
of our scriptures. So if we have the
word of God, Islam is false. If we don't
have the word of God, Islam is false.
Either way, Islam is false. Therefore,
Islam is false. Muhammad Hijab responds
to Wes Huff's video about the Islamic
dilemma. Wes focuses on surah 5:es
46-47 where we read and in their
footsteps we sent Jesus son of Mary
confirming the Torah that had come
before him and we gave him the gospel
wherein is a guidance and a light
confirming the Torah that had come
before him as a guidance and an
exhortation to the reverent. Let the
people of the gospel judge by what God
has sent down therein. Whosoever judges
not by that which God has sent down, it
is they who are
iniquitous. Here's how Wes uses this
passage. In chapter 5 46 and 47 of the
Quran, it lays out a chain of custody
that God sent down the gospel to Jesus
confirming the Torah, both of which
contained guidance and light and said
that the people of the gospel, in other
words, the Christians, must judge by
what God has revealed to them in the
gospel. If they don't judge by the
gospel that God has given to them, then
they're referred to as the defiantly
disobedient. In order to take this
passage seriously, a passage that
addresses me personally as a person of
the gospel, a Christian, I run into a
problem. If I judge the Quran by the
gospel, which I am commanded to do in
order to not be one of the defiantly
disobedient, I find that the Quran
misunderstands, lacks comprehension of,
and outright contradicts the Torah and
the Gospel. So if the Quran is true and
I obey it in this instance by the
standards it tells me to judge by, I
find the Quran false. So the Quran
orders the people of the gospel to judge
by the gospel. If we obey the Quran and
judge by the gospel, we have to conclude
that the Quran is wrong because it
contradicts the gospel. Pretty simple,
right?
Not so fast because our old pal Muhammad
Hijab is going to clean up the Quran's
mess by you guessed it lying. He
mentions in chapter number five verse
number 47 uh that um Allah mentions that
basically you know um you've got you've
got to rule by the Torat right and so
on. And then it
says and whoever does not rule by what
Allah has revealed in the other
disbelievers. Close enough hijab. But
how do you escape the dilemma? I mean
all it takes is for him to have read the
next verse which says
that okay now this is very important
phrase because actually this terminology
is used to describe Allah. So what does
the verse mean? It says and we have sent
down the book i.e the Quran. Now, okay.
We have sent down the Quran to you in
truth to affirm that which has come
before it. The Quran does what now? We
have sent down the Quran to you in truth
to affirm that which has come before it.
Right? The Quran affirms what came
before it, namely the Torah and the
Gospel. Thank you for proving our point.
Let's go ahead and read the verse. So
everyone understands it. Surah
5:48. And we have sent down unto thee
Muhammad the book in truth confirming
the book that came before it and as a
protector over it. This is the verse
hijab goes to to show that the Quran
somehow doesn't confirm the previous
scriptures. So judge between them in
accordance with what God has sent down,
and follow not their caprices away from
the truth that has come unto thee. For
each among you, we have appointed a law
and a way. And had God willed, he would
have made you one community, but he
willed otherwise, that he might try you
in that which he has given you. So v
with one another in good deeds. unto God
shall be your return altogether. And he
will inform you of that wherein you
differ. So Allah sent down the book, the
Quran, confirming the book that came
before it. In context, this is referring
to the Torah and the Gospel and as a
protector over it. The Quran is a
protector over the Torah and the Gospel.
And the verse goes on to say that Allah
gave different communities different
revelations that they're obligated to
follow so that these communities would
be distinct from one another and would
compete with one another in doing good
deeds. How in the name of common sense
does hijab think this is going to help
him when this verse simply proves our
point? The Quran confirms the book that
came before it. This is where hijab goes
to prove that the Quran doesn't confirm
the book that came before it. Hijab is
going to offer a borderline insane
interpretation of the word protector.
Here in Arabic, the word is muiman,
which means protector or guardian.
He's going to claim that when the Quran
says it's the protector or guardian of
the previous scriptures, it somehow
means that the Quran distinguishes
between what's true and what's false in
the previous scriptures.
Well, and a guardian over it. Muan is a
guardian. In this context, there's no
there's nothing this word can mean
except that it's it's a distinguisher
from what is true and what is false. And
that is what the moestors or the exeutes
of old and in the contemporary period
have all understood the word to mean.
Liar. Liar. Liar. Liar. Hijab says that
the word muiman can only mean one thing.
That it's a distinguisher between what's
true and what's false. And that all the
classical exites agree. That's what he
said, right? There's nothing this word
can mean except that it's it's a
distinguisher from what is true and what
is false. And that is what the morphes
or the exodes of old and in the
contemporary period have all understood
the word to mean. In reality, the
classical exedites said it means all
kinds of things. But if Muhammad hijab
thinks it means that a muan is an
authority over what it's guarding, that
a muan is a judge deciding what's true
and what's false in what it's guarding.
Islam is in all kinds of trouble. Let's
see why. Here's some of the commentary
of al-Qi. Remember, everyone agrees on
the meaning of muiman. According to
hijab, a muiman is a guardian that
distinguishes between the true and the
false in what is guarding. Katada said
that the word muiman means testifying to
or conserving. It is said that it means
preserving. Alhassan said it also means
confirming. As in the poem, the book
confirms Muimman, our prophet, and those
with intelligence recognize the truth.
According to this Muslim poem and
hijab's interpretation of Muhamm, the
Quran is a distinguisher of what's true
and what's false in Muhammad. Iban Abbas
said it means ensuring it. Sahed Iban
Juber said the Quran secures the books
before it. Iban Abbass and Al-Hassan
said that Muimman means
trustworthy. As you can see, the
classical exit said that Muiman means
all kinds of things. But look at this
part about mujahed, a very early Quran
commentator. Mujahid said that it means
that Muhammad is the conserver of the
Quran. According to Mujahed, the Quran
isn't the Muahan, the guardian or
protector of the previous scriptures.
Muhammad is the
Muhammian or protector of the Quran. If
that's confusing, let's go back to the
verse and see why Mujahed gives a
different interpretation.
And we have sent down unto thee,
Muhammad, the book in truth, confirming
the book that came before it, and as a
protector over it. Protector here is
Muimman. But who or what is the Muimman,
the guardian or protector? Turns out
there are two options. And we have sent
down unto thee Muhammad, the book in
truth. We've got Muhammad here and we've
got the book, the Quran. Which one is
the Muhamman? Is Muhammad the Muiman or
is the Quran the Muhamman? The majority
position is that the Quran is the
Muhammad, the guardian or protector. If
the Quran is the guardian or protector,
what is it guarding or protecting? The
book that came before it. But there's a
minority position that claims Muhammad
is the Muhamman. If Muhammad is the
Muhamm, the guardian or protector,
what's he guarding or
protecting? The Quran, which in turn
confirms the previous scriptures.
Understand? We've got Muhammad and the
Quran. One of them is the guardian, the
protector. Most Muslim commentators
believe that the Quran is the protector,
which would mean that the Quran is the
protector of the book that came before
it. But some Muslim commentators held
that Muhammad is the protector, which
would mean that Muhammad is the
protector of the Quran. So, Corte points
out that Mujahed said that it means that
Muhammad is the conserver of the
Quran. Why is this important? Well,
apart from exposing Muhammad Hijab as a
total liar when he tells his gullible
fans that Muiman can only mean one thing
and that all of the classical exedites
agree, hijab's view forces us to
conclude that Mujahid and anyone who
agreed with his interpretation were
mushriicks. They were all guilty of
sherk. Think about it. According to
hijab, a muan is a guardian that
distinguishes between what's true and
what's false in whatever he or it is
guarding. So if the Quran is the
guardian of the Torah and the Gospel,
then the Quran distinguishes between
what's true and what's false in the
Torah and the Gospel. The Quran is an
authority over the Torah and the Gospel.
But if Muhammad is the guardian of the
Quran, as Mjahed claimed, and a guardian
decides what's true and what's false in
whatever he's guarding, then Muhammad
was an authority over the Quran.
Muhammad decided what's true and what's
false in the
Quran. You could always say, well,
Muhammad decided that the Quran is all
true. But that wouldn't change the fact
that Muhammad is the authority who
decides what's true and what's false in
the Quran. So Muhammad is a higher
authority than the speech of Allah and
therefore a greater authority than Allah
himself. If Muhammad hijab is correct
about the meaning of
Muhammjah believed that Muhammad was an
authority over the Quran, distinguishing
between what's true and what's false in
the eternal speech of Allah.
If hijab is correct, mujahed believed
that Allah is subordinate to
Muhammad. But in fact, hijab isn't
correct. He's making this up in a
pathetic attempt to escape the Islamic
dilemma. Let's read the entire passage
so you can see how obvious it is that
Allah affirms the inspiration,
preservation, and authority of the Torah
and the Gospel. Verse 43 is about some
Jews who come to Muhammad to judge a
dispute. Allah says, "And how is it that
they come to thee, Muhammad, for
judgment when they have the Torah,
wherein is God's judgment? Why are they
coming to you, Muhammad, when they
already have the Torah? Yet even after
that, they turn their backs and they are
not believers. Truly, we sent down the
Torah, wherein is a guidance and a
light, by which the prophets, who
submitted unto God judged those who are
Jews, as did the sages and the rabbis,
in accordance with such of God's book,
as they were bidden to preserve, and to
which they were witnesses. So fear not
mankind, but fear me, and sell not my
signs for a poultry price. Whosoever
judges not by that which God has sent
down, it is they who are disbelievers.
If you don't judge by the revelation God
gave you, you're a disbeliever. And
therein in the Torah, we prescribe for
them a life for a life, an eye for an
eye, a nose for a nose, an ear for an
ear, a tooth for a tooth, and for wounds
retribution. But whosoever foregoes it
out of charity, it shall be an expeation
for him. Whosoever judges not by that
which God has sent down, it is they who
are wrongdoers. If Jews don't judge by
the Torah, they're
wrongdoers. And in their footsteps, we
sent Jesus, son of Mary, confirming the
Torah that had come before him. And we
gave him the gospel, wherein is a
guidance and a light, confirming the
Torah that had come before him as a
guidance and an exhortation to the
reverend. Let the people of the gospel
judge by what God has sent down therein.
Whosoever judges not by that which God
has sent down, it is they who are
iniquitous. If Christians don't judge by
what Allah revealed in the gospel, we
are
iniquitous. And we have sent down unto
thee, Muhammad, the book in truth,
confirming the book that came before it.
This includes the Torah and the Gospel.
and as a protector over it. So judge
between them in accordance with what God
has sent down, and follow not their
caprices away from the truth that has
come unto thee. For each among you, we
have appointed a law and a way. And had
God w, he would have made you one
community. But he willed otherwise, that
he might try you in that which he has
given you. God tests you by seeing
whether you obey the revelation he gave
you. So vi with one another in good
deeds. Unto God shall be your return
altogether, and he will inform you of
that wherein you
differ. What is this passage obviously
saying? It's saying that Jews have to
judge by the Torah, not by the Quran.
That makes no sense if the Torah has
been corrupted.
Christians have to judge by the gospel,
not by the
Quran. That makes no sense if the Gospel
has been
corrupted. The Gospel confirms the Torah
that came before it, and the Quran
confirms the Torah and the Gospel that
came before it. In what sense is the
Quran a protector or guardian over the
previous scriptures? It's clear when
Jews or Christians try to avoid judging
by the Torah or the Gospel, the Quran
doesn't let them. It sends them right
back to the Torah and the Gospel. The
criticism of Jews and Christians in the
Quran is that they misinterpret and
misrepresent and refuse to obey the
Torah and the Gospel, not that they've
corrupted the text of the Torah and the
Gospel. The Quran guards the Torah and
the Gospel by ordering Jews and
Christians to follow the Torah and the
Gospel. Isn't it ironic that in order to
avoid what the Quran says about the
Torah and the Gospel, Muslims like
Muhammad Hijab have to misinterpret and
misrepresent and outright lie about what
the Quran says, thus bringing on
themselves the same condemnation the
Quran applies to Jews and
Christians. Hijab is doing the same
thing. thing the Quran accuses Jews and
Christians of doing. Perhaps this is
what Muhammad prophesied would happen
when he told his companions that they
would follow the ways of the Jews and
Christians. Sah Muslim the messenger of
Allah said you will certainly follow the
ways of those who came before you
handspan by handspan cubit by cubit
until even if they entered a lizard's
hole you would follow them. We said,
"Oh, messenger of Allah, the Jews and
the Christians." He said, "Who
else?" But it gets worse because
Muhammad Hijab twisted and distorted
more than just Surah
5:48. If you'd like to see further proof
that hijab has to lie to avoid the
Islamic dilemma, Chris from Speaker's
Corner went through hijab's other claims
responding to Wes Huff. You don't want
to miss Chris's video. The link is in
the description.
And remember, archaeologists may solve
the mystery of Stonehenge, but Muslims
will never solve the Islamic dilemma.
[Music]